allerdings gab es zwei von success for
free können sie uns wohl ein paar mehr
von diesem feuchttücher und dazugeben
damit ist der abort profi david toms
geht auf und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen b okay ich habe natürlich
geht es gut wir machen heute einen neuen
pfad tik tok live hacks ich habe wieder
ziemlich viele rausgesucht die mich
persönlich interessieren also ich mach
jetzt nicht so diese standarddünger das
ding ist nämlich es gibt so viele videos
davon und in fast allen videos machen
die das gleiche noch mal kurz zu sagen
wir machen heute credit wir machen
klinik in kombination mit casey wir
schauen uns seiten auf denen man sachen
umsonst bekommt und das ist glaube ich
das langweiligste aber ich konnte es
eigentlich ganz cool deswegen habe ich
mit reingenommen wir versuchen ein
playstation 4 controller mit dem iphone
zu knacken damit zu steuern
du weißt es wahrscheinlich nicht dass
das geht oder nicht mal tolle sachen
erwischt lasst uns mal mit dem ersten
antrag da können wir eigentlich meine
neue streaming extreme ähnliches
passieren anlauf twitch 30 real alex wie
also mit doppel v check das gerne ab und
fällt mir jetzt immer so um 22 uhr los
würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn verloren
und letzten mal hinsetzen dem mama aber
eigentlich nur um reinzukommen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es
funktioniert aber diese typen hat es
vernetzen auch drinnen und irgendwie
geht er mir auf den sack
ich kann seine ich weiß nicht diese
aggression
juli kommen hier wir machen das jetzt
genauso wie der ich bin sogar auf der
amerikanischen apple website wir sind
jetzt hier auf der apple-website auf
airports wir gehen auf buy und machen
das jetzt genauso wie der typ ich nehme
einfach mal mediacom die hier 159 dollar
dann markieren wir den preis also ich
kann mir vorstellen dass ist von der
anzeige klappte hatte untersuchen
ja und das kannst du immer im quelltext
hin werden dann aber das bringt hier gar
nichts null
so und jetzt gehen wir hier weg und
jetzt habe ich so wenn ich zwei mal drin
ich brauche ja nur einmal ist ja klar
dass es nicht funktioniert also man kann
den quelltext erinnern was kannst du
eigentlich fast überall glaube ich aber
der preis an sich wird natürlich nicht
sein wer das glaubt ist absolut dumm ich
weiß das habe ich ja deswegen fahren wir
zweiter vor ort mit dem nächsten las man
ins auto aber ich möchte erstmal raus
ich wollte noch gar nicht raus so wie
wir sind jetzt auf dem weg zum fce alter
ich war da schon so ewig nicht mehr
ich würde auch niemals eigentlich so hin
fahren auch wenn ich früher ich habe das
mal gefeiert der zeit lagen diese dicken
dinger aber jetzt das nicht mehr so
gerne aber das probieren wir mal aus ich
hoffe das klappt auch weil ich habe zum
beispiel vorgestern mein auto revanche
und das interieur ist doch nicht so
klien und deswegen fahren wir zur kfz
kannst dir denken warum junge ich bleibe
euch den live-act noch nicht ein ihr
könnt ja noch bisschen betragen dann
zeige ich euch erstmal also bis gleich
wir stehen jetzt hier bei kerstin drive
der sehr sehr voll ist also
normalerweise wenn ich immer gegen uns
ein video gebraucht habe ich konnte
immer direkt durch waren hier war
niemand und leute wir sind jetzt hier um
ein auto zu putzen
wo ist da der zusammenhang schwierig
oder erwartet ab das ist gut weil ich
hunger habe ich könnte jedes mal mit dem
zehner hier bezahlen aus dem letzten
video klingt illegal aber der ist ja
nicht immer automatisch wenn mehr als
die hälfte vom zehner übrig ist das
dennoch gültig eigentlich oder wie ist
das dann wenn man zur bank geht kann man
einfach leute checkt auf jeden fall das
letzte video ab ganz ganz wichtig sein
können sie uns wohl ein paar mehr von
diesem feuchttüchern dazu geben so war
danke
ja mach ich mir jetzt schon ganz schön
richtig drin danke
ein auto muss auch von innen sauber sein
hier arbeite ich dachte ich muss von
außen ja das können wir auch testen juli
aber erstmal von uns die nette dame
hatten wir jetzt einige dieser tücher
mitgegeben natürlich könnte man auch
einfach einen lappen nehmen ihr könnt
aber auch hier sind hier ist ganz viel
scheiße drauf warum sich die mühe machen
den lappen zu spielen wenn man auch
einfach diese feuchttücher nehmen kann
mit denen das vielleicht noch viel
besser funktioniert als so funktioniert
wie im video kann ich euch sehr gerne
hier jemand kommt halt auch viel besser
in diese ganzen ecken
guck dir das mal hier zum beispiel an
jetzt legt ihr das feucht rein gehst
einmal durch also der dreck auftritt
ganz gut so ist
also auf jeden fall nicht schlecht ja
warte man einmal hier oben und hier kann
man auch ein paar leute mit denen wir
haben ja auf jeden fall mehr als genug
also an sich geht es ja nur darum wenn
man ein paar vor diesen tüchern über hat
immer schön im auto lassen die kann man
gut gebrauchen um das hier so ein
bisschen zu reinigen wenn man sein auto
liebt dann ist das ganz kann man hier
das muss schon jetzt glänzt es wieder
richtig geil
ach so und jetzt machen wir auch die
vogelscheuche weg manchmal dass hier
also diese tauben scheiße ist schon ein
bisschen hartnäckig lassen wir hier
vorne noch das logo einmal reinigen wie
dreckig dass das ist doch die perfekte
aufgabe wenn jetzt so viel langeweile
hat und dem was zu essen geholt hast
kannst du dein auto sauber machen
jetzt werde ich auch endlich wieder
ernst genommen auf den straßen ja leute
am besten ist eigentlich nur thüringen
für draußen hat es jetzt nicht so sein
zweck aber führen kann ich auf jeden
fall empfehlen deswegen sei es merkt
euch das werde ich auch tun und wir
fahren es wieder nach hause die stadt
mal kurz bevor wir los von dir will ich
jetzt machen mich verrückt umbringen
ausprobieren
[Musik]
also theoretisch kann man den ps4
controller mit dem handy verbinden das
habe ich noch nirgendwo gesehen und dann
nicht genug ja natürlich und dann
vielleicht auch games zocken so ps4
taste und share taste passiert ja
irgendwie connected er sich nicht nur
ruhm verbunden und jetzt wo stets da ist
kann ich jetzt noch mitmachen und nicht
irgendwelche spiele spielen letztes mal
mit probleme dieses bei uns das echt
neues alter kommen
das wird jetzt funktionieren also der
leuchtet auf jeden fall roth dh er ist
mit irgendwas connected aber mehr
passiert hier irgendwie nicht gemeinsam
rein oder bogen konnte also der ist in
meinem iphone connected aber irgendwie
kann ich das nicht steuern vielleicht
kann man es nur bei samsung dass du halt
irgendwas damit anfangen kannst weil ja
aber ich bin ja auf jeden fall verbunden
ja was heißt ja nicht dass es direkt
ansteuern kann ist nicht brauchst du
irgendwie zusätzliche app oder sowas
geht ja auch so einfach im video geht es
nicht fertig mit dem iphone also ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass es mit dem
iphone jetzt nicht klappt aber mit
android stelle ich mir das schon möglich
vor ziemlich leicht leute ich habe jetzt
hier noch ein android-handy rausgekramt
und schaut mal her
ich habe den psv controller damit
gekoppelt und man kann hier durchs menü
switchen boom und zum beispiel auf you
tube öffnen
jawohl das geht aber irgendwie nur der
kreis knopf keine ahnung also ein
bisschen wild ist es schon
ich hatte so gefeiert wenn ich dieses
spiel damit jetzt zocken könnt ihr mir
deswegen wohl schüsse auch hier im auto
machen aber es klappt nicht naja leute
dann fahren jetzt wirklich nach hause
weil jetzt zeige ich euch wie man
umsonst auf einer internet seite
irgendwelche sachen umsonst bekommt im
video ist es ein iphone ob das klappt
mag ich zu bezweifeln
aber man kann auf jeden fall was umsonst
regen letzt sollte wir sind wieder bei
uns zu hause und jetzt zeige ich euch
ein live act also wenn das klar das ding
ist das auch ein amerikaner und in
amerika ist ja fast alles möglich
deswegen wir müssen mal schauen ob es
auch in deutschland möglich ist ich habe
das natürlich schon ein bisschen
überprüft noch nicht genauer angeschaut
aber bleibt auf jeden fall jetzt dran
weil interessant ist es allemal
da hat er diese website
das website craigslist group so lag das
state divine der cdu und voila das ist
einfach eine seite im internet auf der
man leuten kostenlose sachen zur
verfügung stellen kann also die stelle
da rein praktisch wie ebay kleinanzeigen
und kostenlos ich kenne die nicht und in
amerika ist das scheint ein großes ding
gibt es allerdings auch für deutschland
das habe ich schon mal geschaut und das
zeige ich euch jetzt mal regen mal kurz
an meinem macbook das ist jetzt
natürlich keine bezahlte werbung oder so
wir geben einfach mal einen free cycle
und dann kann man dahinter schon direkt
germany eingeben und dann kommt hier
oben free cycle groups in germany selber
auf der seite recycle punkt ort das ist
halt wahrscheinlich so dass
amerikanische obwohl ich teste ist
einfach mal gruppen durchsuchen und mal
schauen was jetzt kommt ist okay jetzt
kann man hier erst mal sein land
auswählen
juni zum beispiel suchten neuen
schreibtisch s pass mal auf ründchen
germany und an unsere stadt hier köln
boom
das war das was ich meinte wir haben
jetzt hier praktisch für umsonst ein
ikea babybett sundwig in köln kürten
das ist natürlich ein bisschen lauer
also iphones gibt es hier nicht aber wir
können natürlich auch mal auf andere
städte gehen wie zum beispiel berlin
oder so und hier werden jetzt sachen
aufgeführt wie klappt tisch und stuhl
rosenkohl und musiker latexmatratzen
latexmatratze dann kann man auch noch
eine seite weiter gehen großes ecksofa
von habitat also ich glaube hätte die
seite hier in deutschland bisschen mehr
aufmerksamkeit wäre das ein geiles ding
allerdings für mich ist jetzt nichts
dabei leider auch kein schreibtisch für
dich aber so halbwegs funktionieren tut
schon also wenn irgendwas davon haben
wollt meldet euch einfach bei recycle
punkt trotzdem war das mit den iphones
natürlich ein bisschen sehr übertrieben
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich will war
aber ich kann sich natürlich auch die
nachweise vielleicht ist das ja in
amerika so ihr könnt ja sehr gern mal
eure meinung
in die kommentare schreiben hier gibt es
leider nur ein ecksofa okay leute ich
habe dann überlegt ob ich noch hinten
dranhängen soll wir hatten jetzt schon
vier ich würde sagen das reicht für
diesen part übermorgen gibt es dann
vielleicht noch ein ich hoffe natürlich
jetzt hat euch gefallen ansonsten check
die letzten videos ab da haben wir auch
schon einiges getestet das alles in der
players verlinkt und folgt mir auf
twitter gibt's bestimmt heute abend 22
uhr dann meistens ich meine die meisten
der etage habe nichts zu tun
hongkong / will alex wie die und
instagram auf alex vitek tor auch alex
wie alex und alexa das oder ich habe
mich schon natürlich einander bei den
ganzen kanälen
nein danke fürs zuschauen da nach oben
wir sehen uns heute